so this new record you got has 40 has
larussa lana the russell is someone who
i think has got a lot of promise coming
out of vallejo
um i love his movement i love how he
cuts everyone in on everything he's got
a real just dope mindset when it comes
to his music [ __ ] yeah um
talk about like just how did you guys
initially link up because he's been
doing this thing for a minute yeah yeah
he's been doing this thing for a minute
um
and i like i think i've seen one of his
uh
you know like the the gun company videos
and i was like and i see it and i was
like man that's like you know
most importantly like for him like he
started his like own [ __ ] right like you
know what i'm saying it wasn't like
um
like he didn't get it from like from no
one else it just kind of like he was
like you know what i'm finna just step
and i'm just gonna do what i do
and
and like
seeing that i was like you know i can
recognize when someone's just stepping
out and just being like you know i'm
just like i'm owning my [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying because like that's
something that i do you know
that i've identified with myself so i'm
like oh i got i got identified with that
and you know i'm saying
i just like want to show them some
respect you know i'm saying just like
you feeling me like keep doing your [ __ ]
whenever you feel me like you come to
the house because because that's his
first time working with 40.
his first time yeah um i know i think he
has a song before that's a big deal man
yeah i think he has another song with 40
but yeah but like
yeah like you know i'm saying i think
for me it's just like i wanted to be
able to like
on this song like obviously
bring in like assuring someone new you
know what i'm saying to to a lot of
people and then all and then on top
bring in
40 which is like another layer of music
you know i'm there are fans of you know
i'm saying that obviously bringing my
fans right so it's like it's another
like
i think it's important too because i
feel like in the bay there's like a
track record of artists doing the same
thing like 40 did that
g-eazy did a good job of that yeah you
know helping just try to showcase yeah
she had the rest of the way shout out to
jail for like you feel me like because
he he did that for us you know what i'm
saying and 40 did that for you know i'm
saying for other people but like yeah
like i think before jeezy did that
pretty well so like i mean like i just
want to keep it your family keep it
alive keep it alive you know what i'm
saying so